posthume on va voir si on trouve quelque
chose qui vous plaît ses enfants en
vacances en famille à blois s'apprête à
vivre une expérience inédite visité en
châteaux de la renaissance en tenue
d'époque
il y à logis le pourpoint et les choses
en velours rouge ou bien un ensemble
beige comme ça après quelques
explications et quelques essais voici le
résultat
le premier thème de la visite les
costumes a été abordée sans que les
enfants s'en rende compte
je notamment blandine qui aime beaucoup
se déguiser à la maison ça lui permet de
s'approprier un peu une un milieu
l'histoire un endroit qu'on a déjà
rencontré dans un espace qu'on a déjà eu
l'occasion de voir en famille mais d'une
autre manière et beaucoup plus pratique
poil et de pratique il en est question
pendant cette visite
comment les nobles s'occuper que mange
est il de son sac
la guide conférencière sort tout un tas
d'objets qui illustre ses propos et
permettent aux enfants de rester
attentif
l'artichaut tout à l'heure on parlera
d'une reine de france qui a vécu dans ce
château
catherine de médicis l adorer les
artichauts au milieu de la visite
entracte avec un petit jeu pour
reconnaître les sept rois de france qui
ont vécu quelques temps au château de
blois vaches beaucoup c'est lui ça
retrace l'événement les lacs uci
les choses qu'on faisait au 16e siècle
oui ça les motive beaucoup là ils sont
motivés pour faire la visite on n'a pas
à les traîner ses miracles au bout d'une
heure et quart les enfants sont toujours
concentrés deux fois par jour ils
peuvent ainsi apprendre sans effort une
partie de l'histoire de la renaissance
en immersion au château de blois